odette et artisans d'art elle fait
sécher des fleurs pour les coller sur
différents objets à cause de la crise
sanitaire elle a subi de grosses pertes
sur ses ventes
alors elle se réjouit de pouvoir
présenter ses créations ça nous fait
vraiment du bien c'est parce que bon
c'est un moment où de partage où les
gens auront envie d'acheter
c'est vrai que c'est appréciable pour
nous un ça c'est sûr même constat pour
andry auto entrepreneur depuis sept ans
il crée des petits objets avec des
ardoises d'habitude il participe à
environ 5 marché de noël à cette période
cette année celui d'aubigny sera le seul
pour son activité moi c'est un
complément donc c'est vrai que j'ai
souffert aussi que s'il ya quand même
des charges et ainsi de suite
mais malgré tout je suis quand même
relativement content de retrouver en à
dire les marchés malgré les contraintes
sanitaires que l'on connaît sens de
circulation imposées port du masque et
gels hydro-alcooliques
le public a répondu présent cette année
ça a été très dur et puis on vient et
fait revivre aussi un ont pensé à eux
on a tous eu besoin de sortir et de
renouer un petit peu avec enfin de
retrouver un lien social et oui c'est
important de faire vivre nos artisans
locaux organisés pour la première fois
par une association caritative
le marché de noël dobbin in a bien
failli pas se tenir avec la crau vie 19
il a fallu s'adapter les normes nous
impose de fans ou supprime plus
exactement tout ce qui est dégustation
et
et buvette là nous aurons que
des investissements consentis par les
exposants pour pour nous faire recette
mais bon le but n'était pas de
de faire une super recettes on aurait
bien été les seuls à faire une super
recettes en cette super période les
fonds récoltés serviront notamment à
financer de nombreuses actions pour les
résidents en ehpad essentiels pendant
cette période c'est aussi ça la magie de
noël